straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the shocking new report on the britney
spears conservatorship
did a pop icon called 9-1-1 to report
abuse just hours before her emotional
courtroom plea
this is someone who's extremely high
functioning federal investigators arrive
in surfside florida
the questions and legal implications of
the deadly condo collapse
the whole world wants to know what
happened here plus the ex-wife of former
nba player lorenz wright
wants to withdraw her guilty plea to his
murder but
her attorney fails to show up for court
i want to try i want the public to hear
the real stuff that really really
happened
and investigators take the stand in the
trial of a colorado father
accused of murdering his own son why did
mark redwine not try to call or
text 13 year old dylan redwine after he
disappeared
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
britney spears's long time manager calls
it quits it's the latest development
after the star spoke out against her
conservatorship
and as a new report details what's been
happening behind the scenes
angela levy has more brian an
investigative story from the new yorker
magazine
offers new details about the
conservatorship as the man who helped
launch britney spears career
steps down larry rudolph has been with
britney spears since she was 13 with the
exception of a brief break
now in a letter obtained by deadline
rudolph says he's resigning as spears
manager rudolph writes that he hasn't
spoken to spears in two and a half years
and he's been told that britney has been
voicing her intention
to officially retire news of rudolph's
resignation comes as the new yorker
published a bombshell story
entitled britney spears's
conservatorship nightmare
the story claims britney spears called
9-1-1 last month
the night before she spoke to the
probate court to report conservatorship
abuse
ronan farrow and gia tolentino appeared
on good morning america to discuss the
story
this appears to be a new escalation in
the case and
you know it accords with what we learned
in her testimony the next day which is
she really did
describe this in terms of criminal abuse
the new yorker reports
on a number of claims including a family
friend who gave testimony that helped
create the conservatorship in a brief
hearing
jacqueline butcher is quoted as saying
at the time
i thought we were helping and i wasn't
and i helped a corrupt family seize
all this control
now the new yorker story reports a
number of incidents that are
questionable regarding spears's father
jamie he is labeled as
really the driving force behind the
conservatorship and according to the
story
anyone who tried to question it was
ousted from britney spears's life
jamie spears has maintained through his
lawyer that he has been
upset that his daughter is suffering and
that he has been looking out for her
best interest
brian thanks angela joining us today is
criminal defense attorney nicole debord
and terry austin nicole could the firing
of her manager mean there is just
less of britney's to control making it
easier to dissolve the conservatorship
that's what it looks like from here i
think that a manager stepping down
indicates that he doesn't believe
there's a need for him to be there in
that role
and it does seem that this gives the
court more leeway
now terry if she does retire like nicole
is saying i guess it makes a little bit
easier but
what do you think the court needs to do
to make this all work
and have they started to make it right
you know i think the court has been very
hesitant up until now but i think it's
just a matter of
time like nicole said we saw that the
manager just stepped down
and we saw before that that the judge
did approve
bessemer trust resigning as the
co-conservator so
hopefully her father will voluntarily
step down and if
not now that the court is seeing
everyone else is
backing away and you know they are
actually trying to listen to
britney's wishes maybe the court will do
the same thing let's hope so anyway
yeah we've heard that even jamie spears
her father wants there to be some sort
of evidentiary hearing to at least hear
her out now internet you reported
earlier that the new yorker reports that
jamie spears uh has spent a lot of money
on crisis pr
and even brittany's lawyer is making a
lot of money off the conservatorship
right
yeah according to the new yorker story
they say that her lawyer her court
appointed lawyer samuel ingham is making
about a half a million dollars a year
and even in los
angeles money that's nothing to sneeze
at that's a lot of money to be paid each
year
and the story also reports that jamie
spears was using money from the
conservatorship
to pay for crisis pr management that was
anywhere from five hundred dollars per
hour to nine hundred dollars per hour
depending on what agency he
was using and that cost was really
adding up as he was trying to manage the
fallout from all of this
yeah i was curious to see how those
payments were being dashed out
um just a quick follow-up terry in terms
of these uh this conservatorship we're
talking about the judge needing to do a
little bit more
do you think that britney spears can go
even further to a higher court and say
hey this judge isn't doing enough
i might need to resolve this at a higher
level
you know i think that makes sense brian
if the judge continues to ignore her
wishes
she can actually go to court herself and
try to get everyone removed so
i'm hoping that the judge will do the
right thing but you know if not
she should be able to take it to another
court or a higher court so that this can
get resolved as we said before
i think that the whole conservative
system has to be revamped so that
the people who are put into the system
have the right to make their own
decisions
yeah it seems for people like brittany
it's very easy to get into very
difficult to get back
out of this has been a 13-year
conservatorship
thank you everyone turning now to other
top legal news attorneys for
r kelly are asking for more time before
his trial in new york that's scheduled
for next month
the singer's attorneys will ask a judge
to delay his upcoming trial
for federal sex trafficking charges r
kelly has been in mandatory quarantine
in jail for the past two weeks
since he was moved to brooklyn from
chicago his newly hired defense attorney
says he is facing quote
herculean effort to get up to speed on
the case a hearing on the matters is now
scheduled for thursday
a former campus police officer in
cincinnati will not face federal civil
rights charges for shooting an unarmed
black man during a traffic stop
two trials for raid tense and resulted
in hung jurors on murder charges
the department of justice reviewed the
shooting and right before the holiday
weekend
announced it was closing the case tenson
shot and killed sam dubose during a
traffic stop in july 2015
as dubose tried to drive away the
university of cincinnati paid the dubose
family nearly 5 million dollars
in a civil rights settlement
still ahead on law and crime daily the
ex-wife of a former nba
player wants to take back her guilty
plea to his murder
but first the ongoing investigation into
the surf side condo collapse
the legal implications of the deadly
disaster as rescuers continue to look
for victims
under the rubble
[Music]
welcome back the death toll is
continuing to rise in serve side florida
and as rescuers brace for severe weather
due to a tropical storm
federal investigators are watching
closely we were focused squarely
on search and rescue but while
preserving all
possible evidence the national institute
of standards and technology is leading
the federal investigation
into the deadly disaster and they have
been able to tag
all of the evidence that has been
already gathered and they are embedded
and working with our police department
to tag
everything that is coming through the
pile the agency will conduct a full
technical investigation
to determine the cause of the building
collapse they've also conducted lidar
about 3d picture taking of the building
before the demolition
and of course they've been speaking as
well to many many people with
information
that could contribute to understanding
the causes five lawsuits have been filed
so far in the case
on friday a miami-dade county judge
placed the champlain tower south condo
association
into receivership a lawyer for the
association told the judge that the
board reportedly
has about 48 million dollars in
insurance coverage and
their oceanfront land is valued at 30 to
50 million dollars
the judge authorized the receiver to
make direct payment to the residents
families who've lost loved ones and
residents in need of temporary housing
will each receive up to ten thousand
dollars two thousand dollars will be
provided to cover funeral expenses
the hearing stems from a class-action
lawsuit filed on june 24th
the condo board voted to accept the
receivership and distribute funds
the attorney for the association says
every living and accounted for board
member
was present at the meeting one member
remains unaccounted for
the judge says he wants the case to be
resolved in a year i
look forward to learning the truth as do
we all
but i think it will be a while till
everything is
is understood and i'm very confident
that especially the federal
investigative team
will get to the bottom of this and that
will learn
what what happened what could have been
prevented and how to make sure it never
happens again
let's bring in criminal defense attorney
nicole deborah and terry austin
terry the condo is going to fight back
on all of these charges
could they use the fact that residents
were warned to make these
charges go away you know i don't think
that that'll be a successful defense
i think the condo board can try to claim
that the residents had some
responsibility and that they
lacked the ability or the desire to move
forward with these
sort of you know repairs and you know
they could
say that there's contributory negligence
here but it's not going to absolve the
condo board of responsibility
clearly the condo board had information
and they should have acted upon that
information they had a duty to these
residents the residents really
wasn't you know they weren't able to
have access to that so
i think the condo board may be pointing
fingers at the residents but at the
end of the day they're still going to be
held somewhat responsible for what
occurred here
absolutely i would agree there nicole
they are still looking for over a
hundred people while collecting evidence
can you describe what an investigation
like this may look like
from a criminal standpoint from a
federal standpoint
there are different things that they
will be looking for compared to the
civil side
they're going to be trying to determine
from a records standpoint
who knew what and when in terms of
what should have and could have been
done to prevent all of these deaths
it's just a horrible horrible tragedy
and there may be some criminal liability
depending on what was known and when i
think sounds probably gonna be a lot of
emails a lot of back and forth
in terms of uh like you said who knew
what and when
terry do you think it was a wise move to
appoint a receiver to manage
lawsuits i definitely think that was a
wise move this is a good judge he's
making sure
that all these five lawsuits move
forward and that they move
forward rapidly he's actually warned the
attorneys for the condo board
that he wants no delays he wants this to
be all resolved
he's given the receiver the ability to
immediately
make payments and to resolve any issue
so i think it was a good move i think it
was smart
on the condo board's part to decide to
select
a reserve receiver who could be
objective frankly they don't have any
investment in this
so it's the best move all around i think
then of course really quick
do you see the facts here i know we
don't have much yet but when you look at
this type of case
do you see that they're most likely
going to settle this or do you think
that this could be something that can
drag out in terms of litigation even
though the judge wants it to end in a
year
boy from here it sure looks like they
ought to settle this and quick
the public is watching i think any
efforts by legal teams to delay
what these results should be will be
something that brings on a lot of scorn
so i expect that it will settle
and it's just going to be a question of
for how much definitely all eyes are on
florida when it comes to this condo
thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily we hear
from expert phone analysts in the latest
developments
in the colorado first mark redwine trial
plus
the murder of former nba player lorenz
wright his
ex-wife now claiming her innocence but
her attorneys are nowhere to be found
the latest after the break
welcome back the ex-wife of a former nba
player wants her guilty plea for murder
thrown out
but a hearing was delayed after her
attorney couldn't be found
memphis basketball player lorenz wright
was shot to death in july 2010
seven years later his ex-wife sharia
wright robinson and her accused
accomplice
billy ray turner were charged in
wright's murder she pled guilty in 2019
and was sentenced to 30 years in prison
but she's now claiming her confession
was coarse
and that she didn't have effective
counsel a hearing was scheduled for
tuesday but was reset
because her attorney couldn't be reached
frustrating the court
and the victim's mother i want her to
get a new trial
i want to try this lord give her a try
because you get what you're going to get
what you deserve if you get your trial
i'm ready for a trial
that plea that was just something to do
on that day
so you in support of attack the judge
overturning them yes sir yes sir
so so all the facts can get out so
everybody get the right time
30 years ain't no right to laurence
ain't gonna be back in 30 years
spring america criminal defense attorney
nicole de board and co-host terry austin
nicole not showing up to court when your
client is claiming ineffective
assistance of counsel
not a good look can you break down what
that claim is
sure boy not a good look at all and when
a trial lawyer's
performance falls below the objective
standard of reasonableness
reasonableness that is literally what
ineffective assistance of counsel
is defined by as the law says under
strickland
and in this case i think there's no
question that these are unprofessional
errors when you don't even
post for a court hearing absolutely now
terry wright's claim argues basically
the sixth amendment because you have
that constitutional right
uh to affect in a sense of the council
was violated but how do you think the
judge will rule
and how would that affect her plea
you know it really all depends on what
exactly
happened with the plea did she have
effective
assistance of counsel was she told what
her rights were
obviously under the sixth amendment you
have a right to effective assistance of
counsel you have a right to an impartial
jury
and if she didn't know all of these
things she could have i guess
given her rights away but if the judge
explained it to her if her attorney
explained it to her
i think that she is not going to get
this plea withdrawn because as long as
she knew
all of her rights at the time and they
went through the proper procedures
then withdrawing the plea at this point
might just be
very difficult very very difficult for
this type of claim you not only to show
that the
lawyer's actions affected the case but
that she took this plea
both not knowingly and not voluntarily a
very high hurdle
to overcome but we'll keep you with
updates on all of that when we come back
the lack of communication between a
father and his missing son
could this evidence lead to a guilty
verdict in the case against mark redwine
and how a failed test by a cadaver dog
might help the defense
our legal analysis next
welcome back now on to the trials we're
covering here on the lawn crime network
starting with california vs robert durst
the real estate air is accused of
shooting and killing his best friend
susan berman
in her california home in december 2000.
robert durst was also on trial for the
murder and dismemberment
of his former neighbor morris black
durst admitted to the dismemberment but
was acquitted for the murder
by claiming self-defense the prosecution
has been reading transcripts from that
trial to offer evidence they say is
relevant to this case
however court has been dark due to
medical appointments for the defendant
who is suffering from different forms of
cancer
and now to colorado where an electronic
device forensic expert
took the stand in the case against mark
redwine
mark redwine is on trial for the murder
of his 13 year old son
dylan redwine dylan was on a court
mandated visit to his father when he
mysteriously
disappeared his remains were found in a
wooded area not far from his father's
house
this happened after dylan allegedly
found photos of his father
cross-dressing in women's lingerie while
eating feces from a diaper
a forensic expert who specializes in
electronic devices
testified there was no attempt from mark
redwine to communicate to his son
after he went missing were you able to
detail any calls
made from mark redwine's own the dylan
redwine's phone based on his phone
itself
on november 18th
up until december 15th when the call
logs began
so i don't recall if there were any you
said the call logs started on december
15th right correct
so you didn't have any call information
prior to that time no i did not
we also heard from an fbi phone analyst
who testified
to something similar saying that there
was no communication between the
defendant and his son
the night he went missing so you're
aware just generally from the
investigation that dylan was reported
missing
on the 19th roughly around 4 30
and then that was the first night that
his whereabouts were unknown
what is the last time that the defendant
attempts to call dylan redwine
on the night of november 19th
7 34 pm and what is the next time
that the defendant tries to call dylan
redwine's phone
here it is on the next page on the 20th
7 19 am so roughly 12 hours
overnight first 90's missing the
defendant doesn't attempt to call
that's correct and a human remains
detection expert testified specifically
about the cadaver dogs used in the case
one of the dogs allegedly failed to test
during training and the chart just like
this
yes and in that testimony in your direct
testimony
you talked specifically about molly's
first attempt to certify right
she failed right i think she was just
too green
um too immature and
we learned what we needed to work on
and then did you go back after that it
indicates on there there was a false
positive and two misses correct
yes so that's the kind of thing that's
going to keep a dog from certifying
right
yes nicole mark redwine didn't call or
even look for his son dylan
how do you see either side using this
fact to help their case
i feel like the prosecution is really
going to use this to demonstrate that he
knew that there was no reason to reach
out to his son because his son was
already dead
on the other side i can see the
prosecution or excuse me the defense
trying to say
well he didn't think anything terrible
had happened so there was no urgent need
to try to seek out his son
i think prosecution's got the stronger
argument absolutely i think most parents
especially most reasonable parents say
hey if my kid goes missing
i'm going to call i'm going to text i'm
going to find out who their friends are
go to their
local hangout spots but this father
nothing i think even a lazy
fair father would do a little bit more
than that terry defense council made a
big deal about the failed certification
did he make any points or was he barking
up the wrong tree
he was definitely barking up the wrong
tree brian he made no points whatsoever
in fact i think he
lost points the specialist the canine
specialist who was on the stand she did
an amazing job she talked about molly
and how she trained molly and how molly
was certified and so she did fail one
test in 2008 but she passed all of the
rest of the test through 2015
and she actually got certified for
reliability so
i think that the defense made much too
much about the fact that this
one failed test didn't show up because
in fact it did show up
and the specialist said she talked about
it on direct and the judge got a little
upset
as far as the defense was concerned and
he said look i think she testified about
that
and that doesn't look good to the jury
so i think he lost points and he should
have just
let that one go yeah i think he's trying
to make a mountain out of a molehill i
get where he's going with that
but especially my doubt my dog is
trained in german obedience she failed a
or two but still works pretty well i
think most people who have dogs
understand that they're not always
perfect but they can get there
thank you both for being here and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you